In this video, I'm going to give you some tips or a tip on how you can improve your wind rate with ABC trading strategy. Let's assume that you have a POI, it could be an auto block or a fair value gap on a higher timeframe. You can also take this into consideration that you had a lower low, lower high, and then you had a market structure break or break of structure. Usually, when you are trading smart money or auto floor trading strategy, you would take your entry.
from this level. However, if you want to increase your ABC
strategy win rate, what you can do is look for an ABC pattern,
near your POI, and the C leg goes into your POI.
Like this. So we have an ABC and the C leg
goes into your POI. Now that is going to increase your win rate
tremendously. Okay? Not tremendously, but it's going to give
like a five percent or 10 percent increase to your win rate.
So you are going to then follow the rules again, right?
As I have taught the APC strategy,
you then wait for a market structure shift
with displacement, with volume,
and then you take your entry from the extreme fairly gap
and caboom.
So this is something that you can take into consideration.
All right?
What you wanna do is you wanna identify a POI,
it could be an auto block, it could be a fairly gap,
a high time frame, right?
And then you wait for price to give you an ABC pattern near your P.O.I.
And the C leg goes into the P.O.I. right?
And when it does, then you can look for a market structure shift
within the range, which is here, right?
So if the price breaks the structure somewhere around here,
you look for your entry and boom.
Trust me, it's going to increase your win rate by 10 to even 15%.
So yeah, I hope you like the tip.
and let's move on to the next video.